[Music]
what is it you think we do here over
lifeguard I mean it's what happened to
that last pretty boy recruit you guys
you just my boobs I'm not here here
[Music]
welcome to Baywatch just near for the
qualifiers one direction when is this
late guard hazy oh you dick you turned
the canals into the next game we were in
lifeguard pursuit hall okay except
there's no such thing as lifeguard
pursuit good night night vision
welcome to Baywatch our team is the
elite of the elite there's a high soul
of this very Beach come on feet make my
pecs a little bigger and don't cover on
my front pump you got huge dick big dick
a little firmer you're for qualifies I
don't have to try out and that Brody
comes to gold medal hey Brody
yes we still need your classic my baby
hey not here here
did you gonna be on this team one
direction see any people in
refrigerators very much exs much I'm
fast it's drug murder a dead body on our
Beach and it all started once she took
over some people are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
does that your lifeguard not only leave
[Music]
yeah why does he look like she's running
as roma she's the reason I believe in
God yeah we gotta call her Gunther where
the hell is Brody I don't wear makeup
right my wedding makeup a little much
I look legit hot everybody almost yet
Nathan born in Kashi no mr. go why are
we any more got to get some hard
evidence I'm not coming forward it out
shall we hide please I'm playing London
all three murders are empty what you big
natural how much it's just a little dead
man's back the chronic liquid fat that
we stopped you to base
you
you